Michael schellenberger is one of the
best journalists in this country his
work is done sub stack he just wrote a
piece on exactly this today he joins us
tonight with his perceptions uh Mike
what do you make of like what are we
watching here exactly and what does it
mean
we're good to be with you Tucker and of
course anybody who saw the video of the
young man in Memphis Tennessee being
beaten by the police is horrified by it
yeah but I think you're absolutely right
the anti-police movement has blood on
its hands at least 3 000 additional
black homicides have occurred since the
George Floyd uh protests of 2020 the
Georgia and also the George Floyd riots
we've seen about 30 unarmed
African-Americans killed in 2022 60
police officers but over 8 000
African-Americans likely were killed in
2022 and this is due to this obviously
this anti-policing movement it's led to
uh people the police leaving the force
in droves the demoralization of the
police the pulling back of the police so
this is really quite Insidious quite
dangerous situation and I think that you
know as we look at these protests going
forward you have to distinguish between
people who are expressing genuine
demands for police reform from the
anti-police movement which has turned
into one of the most counterproductive
violent movements in American history
unless its real goal is not what they
say it is unless its real goal is to
federalize local police and control
every organization in the country with
guns I mean do you think that's possible
I mean what we're seeing right now is
the decimation of police forces police
departments are you know up and down all
across the country three to five hundred
police officers short that's why we're I
mean it's interesting the protests you
just covered in Memphis displaying that
there's not enough police officers and
the result is that the people that they
said they wanted to save African
Americans have disproportionately
suffered so at least 3 000 additional
black homicides since the George Floyd
protests again against 30 unarmed black
deaths last year it doesn't even compare
no it really doesn't and thank you you
always have the numbers we appreciate it
Michael Schellenberg
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight